en los bazares de irán los precios se
dispararon desde que donald trump rompió
el acuerdo nuclear e impuso nuevas
sanciones a la república islámica
técnicamente las exportaciones
estadounidenses a iran están prohibidas
sin embargo muchos comerciantes están
consiguiendo sortear las sanciones estas
nueces vienen de california
bastidas estos frutos secos tardan nueve
meses en llegar desde eeuu como muchos
van a china luego de china white y de
uruguay irán en la factura dice que
vienen de china debido a las sanciones
los productos de importaciones son
escasos y caros la inflación es
demasiado alta un empleado ordinario ya
no puede llegar a fin de mes
abajo los eeuu
según el banco mundial la inflación ha
alcanzado el 48 por ciento en un año
este barrio de teherán está
especializado en la venta de piezas de
automóviles debido a las sanciones la
reparación de vehículos europeos se ha
convertido en un reto la mayoría de
automovilistas ya no pueden permitirse
comprar piezas originales y recurren a
copias más baratas
voy a quedarme con esta pieza también
necesitaría una luz de techo trasera
cuánto cuesta una luz trasera 190.000
en la última vez fueron 150.000 porque 2
no podemos conseguir las piezas
directamente así que recurrimos a
intermediarios turcos que nos las venden
algunos precios como las de las
pastillas de freno se han multiplicado
por 10 otras
select
al grado sería mucho más fácil si se
levantarán esas sanciones
pero yo no creo en ellos el presidente
estadounidense joe biden ha decidido
retomar las negociaciones nucleares con
la república islámica de irán el mayor
reto del próximo presidente iraní será
obtener la retirada de las sanciones
económicas internacionales